quarantäne für einreisende und
heimkehrer über die bundesregierung
einführen
außerdem soll der mittelstand leichter
an krone hilfskredite kommen in
österreich stellt lockerungen in
aussicht nach den feiertagen könnten wir
geschäfte in mehreren schritten wieder
öffnen und ostern ohne gäste der
hotelbranche bricht das wichtige
geschäft über die ferien und feiertage
weg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg eine neue woche im
zeichen der kubakrise guten abend schön
dass sie dabei sind
es ist die dritte woche in der die
deutsche wirtschaft und das öffentliche
leben in einer art künstlichen koma
liegen
über ein ende der beschränkungen will
die bundesregierung noch nicht reden
stattdessen beschloss das sogenannte
korona kabinett heute weitere
einschränkungen aber auch weitere
wirtschaftshilfen mittelständische
firmen sollen einfacher an dringend
benötigte kredite kommen und zwar
innerhalb weniger tage die
bundesregierung will firmen unterstützen
die ihre produktion auf schutzkleidung
und masken umstellen und wer nach
deutschland einreist muss ab freitag vor
zwei wochen in häuslicher quarantäne
mit ausnahmen zum beispiel von
berufspendlern andreas kienast cancelled
gestrichen es sind inzwischen weniger
als ein dutzend flüge am tag die noch
ankommen in berlin-tegel die zweiwöchige
quarantäne dürfte nur wenige linien
passagiere betreffen aber die tausenden
deutschen die immer noch aus aller welt
heimkehren
die regel gilt für alle einreisenden zu
land zu wasser auf dem luftweg ausnahmen
werden für pendler lastwagenfahrer oder
lokführer gemacht jetzt geht es noch
einmal darum dass wir den freien
reiseverkehr der berufspendler und der
beruflich unterwegs seinen garantieren
und trotzdem bei den vielen die
vielleicht auch nach deutschland
zurückkehren maximalen gesundheitsschutz
veranlassen krisen routine in berlin
immer montags takt jetzt das
krisenkabinett und beschließt heute
weitere hilfen für deutschlands
mittelstand um eine pleitewelle zu
verhindern will der staat haften für
bankkredite von bis zu 800.000 euro von
uns dann in diesem fall 100 prozent
verbürgt so dass keine eigene bewertung
der bank notwendig ist und mit dieser
100% verbürgung ist es dann auch möglich
dass das ganz schnell ausgereicht werden
kann um die herstellung von
schutzausrüstung anzukurbeln prüft die
regierung eine abnahmegarantie für
firmen die
produktion umstellen denn selbst wenn
die heute in potsdam mal ein paar
kartons aus china ankommen reichen
anzahl und qualität nicht aus wir sind
gerade mal in der lage jeder praxis 10
masken von unterschiedlicher qualität
zur verfügung zu stellen das ist nicht
viel
wir brauchen viel mehr gebrauchen
millionen von masten für die nächsten
wochen und tagen deswegen braucht es
dringend eine task force von seiten der
bundesregierung die eine eigenproduktion
von schutzausrüstung hier in deutschland
gemeinsam mit den europäischen nachbarn
koordiniert eine masken pflicht wie in
anderen ländern erweckt die
bundesregierung wenn es genug masken
gibt und wenn die ausgangssperre
gelockert wird
die lockerung werde in stufen erfolgen
heißt es das kabinett orientiere sich
dafür an verschiedenen experten studien
welche schlüsse wir daraus ziehen können
wir ihnen aber heute noch nicht sagen
aber nachdenken tun wir und auf jeden
fall wird es ein schrittweises vorgehen
seien so viel kann man auch schon sagen
ein wiederaufbauprogramm hält merkel für
die eu nötig das umstrittene wort
eurobonds benutzt sie aber nicht von an
unsere hauptstadtkorrespondenten chuck
und allah banerjee die bundesregierung
nennt ja noch keinen zeitpunkt ab dem es
lockerungen geben könnte contra warum
nicht die bundesregierung setzt ganz
offensichtlich vor allem auf kontrolle
kontrolle über das virus soweit das eben
möglich ist kontrolle über die
infektionszahlen über die ausbreitung
und diese kontrolle ist momentan eben
noch nicht wirklich möglich es gibt
nicht genug masken es gibt nicht genug
tests man muss an vielen stellen
nachbessern und nacharbeiten und solange
das nicht passiert können kann man
erstmal nicht auf eine lockerung der
maßnahmen hoffen angela merkel hat heute
in der pressekonferenz auch etwas
bemerkenswertes gesagt nämlich es könnte
den vorwurf geben wenn man zu früh
zurückkehrt zu einer normalität und die
zahlen dann wieder hoch gehen
möglicherweise auch todeszahlen
hochgehen das ist dass man sich eben
fahrlässig verhalten hat das war nicht
ganz genau ihre worte aber das steht
schon sehr deutlich dahinter
die sorge davor nachher der
fahrlässigkeit angeklagt zu werden wenn
man sich zu schnell wieder zurück zur
normalität drängen lässt und dabei die
das virus nicht unter kontrolle hat
italien frankreich und spanien fordern
mehr europäische solidarität vor allem
auch finanzielle hilfe wie steht die
kanzlerin dazu das war vielleicht aus
sicht der bundesregierung heute das
wichtigste signal olaf scholz und
außenminister maß hatten sich heute
morgen schon in fünf verschiedenen
ländern mit zeitungsartikel zu wort
gemeldet um den eindruck zu vermeiden
dass deutschland hier keine solidarität
zeigen möchte
und auch angela merkel hat in der
pressekonferenz sich sehr
fast schon pathetisch geäußert und dort
gesagt europa steht vor der größten
bewährungsprobe und jetzt heißt
natürlich daran solidarität zu zeigen
auch für deutschland sei das von größter
im interesse was man allerdings dazu
sagen muss ist dass die deutsche
solidarität eben nicht ganz so ausfällt
wie sich die nachbarstaaten und die euro
staaten vor allem das vorstellen
eurobonds corona bonds kommen hier
offensichtlich für die bundesregierung
weiterhin nicht infrage
man hat aber andere möglichkeiten in
aussicht gestellt über den europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus und hat auch
deutlich gemacht deutschland stünde
bereit garantien zu übernehmen in höhe
von sieben milliarden für ein
europäisches kurzarbeitergeld also das
war heute eine botschaft die berlin
offensichtlich sehr wichtig war vor
allem vor dem morgigen treffen der
euro-finanzminister dankeschön nach
berlin chuck und alaba nati und jetzt
der blick auf die aktuellen zahlen in
deutschland da gehen die neuinfektionen
weiter leicht zurück eine entwicklung
die hoffnung gibt die aber nach wie vor
kein sicherer trend ist an seinem stern
hatte details mehr fälle mehr tote die
zahlen dieser krise sie steigen weiter
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland mehr als
100000 infektionen durch tests bestätigt
das ist der stand heute vor einer halben
stunde mehr als 1600 menschen sind in
verbindung mit 19 gestorben
hoffnung macht der blick auf diese
grafik wo steigende zahlen etwas gutes
sind anfang märz hat sich die zahl der
erkrankten noch alle zwei tage
verdoppelt mittlerweile sind es 10,4
tage das tempo der ausbreitung wird also
langsam aber erst ab einer verdopplung
zeit von etwa 14 tagen will die
regierung erwägen die drastischen
antivirus maßnahmen in deutschland zu
lockern
abstand halten zu hause bleiben kontakte
meiden das alles wird also noch eine
ganze weile weiter gelten in deutschland
in österreich macht kanzler sebastian
kurz der bevölkerung hoffnung schon nach
ostern könnten die maßnahmen gegen
korona gelockert werden
aber nur etwas und auch nur vielleicht
österreich hatte sich strenge regeln
gegeben
raus darf man dort nur zum einkaufen
arbeiten und sport machen treffen in
gruppen verboten
schulen und universitäten geschlossen
auch geschäfte und restaurants sind zu
öffnen dürfen bislang nur
lebensnotwendige leben etwa supermärkte
und apotheken britta hilpert leere
pisten geschlossene gasthäuser strenge
kontrollen seit drei wochen steht
österreich fast still
die infektionszahlen steigen nur noch
langsam
die ungeduld aber schnell zeit für einen
fahrplan in die normalität die regierung
kündigt den an für die zeit nach ostern
aber nur unter einer bedingung dass sie
auch wenn es schwer fällt weiter
diszipliniert alle maßnahmen einhalten
wenn wir das nicht tun dann wird es
unmöglich sein diesen ambitionierten
plan den ich gerade präsentiert habe
durchzusetzen
nach ostern also dürfen kleine geschäfte
und baumärkte öffnen ab anfang mai dann
auch die großen und friseure mitte mai
könnten gastronomie und schulen langsam
wieder hochfahren
allerdings sieht der korona fahrplan
ebenfalls vor die masken pflicht
auszuweiten auf den öffentlichen
nahverkehr reaktionen
ich glaube es wird länger dauern also
ich hab schon bedenken dass es eventuell
zu früh gemacht wird das ist ein seil
akt zwischen der zufriedenheit der der
bevölkerung und der wirtschaft und
gleichzeitig auch der dass ein demenz
des virus österreich lockert und wird
strenger mann setzte
mehr auf individuelle verantwortung und
lockert dafür einige generelle maßnahme
doch alles unter vorbehalt sollten die
infektionen wieder steigen werden die
lockerungen sofort wieder zurückgenommen
großveranstaltungen und reisefreiheit
jedenfalls wird es wohl bis zum sommer
nicht geben
in großbritannien hat die queen mit
ihrer historischen fernsehansprache
offenbar einen nerv getroffen
die 93 jährige machte ihrem volk mut
reeves zugleich zum durchhalten auf und
zu eiserne disziplin in dieser pandemie
premier ist jenson der anfangs die
gefahr herunter gespielt hatte und
mittlerweile selbst infiziert ist wurde
ins krankenhaus eingeliefert
aus london andreas stamm von fieber
gekennzeichnet eine folge der korona
erkrankung boris johnson vergangenen
freitag sein letzter öffentlicher
auftritt per internet-video bevor er
gestern abend ins krankenhaus musste per
tweet lässt johnson am mittag wissen auf
anraten der ärzte und erzieher er sich
einigen routinetests das kroner
krisenmanagement der regierung übernahm
deshalb außenministerrat als sein
stellvertreter
ich versichere ihnen der premier hatte
eine angenehme nacht im krankenhaus und
ist bester dinge
er ist dort weiter zur beobachtung wird
regelmäßig über die entwicklungen
informiert und führt weiter die
regierung an die erklärung der regierung
äusserst knapp bleibt viel raum für
spekulation
britische medien berichten es gehe den
premier schlechter als zugegeben wird
doch nicht nur johnson auch seine corona
politik leidet unter schweren vorwürfen
denn schon zu normalen zeiten operiert
der nationale gesundheitsdienst nhs an
der belastungsgrenze
ein grund die harten sparmassnahmen seit
der finanzkrise 2008 unter johnsons
konservativen vorgänger die zahlen
sprechen eine deutliche sprache
in deutschland gibt es pro einwohner
dreimal mehr krankenhausbetten fast
fünfmal mehr intensivbetten es fehlt nun
wohl an schutzausrüstungen
beatmungsgeräten sauerstoff es wird zu
wenig getestet und der vorwurf lautet
auch bei boris johnson zu spät gehandelt
habe und dann auch nur halbherzig in
dieser situation appellierte gestern
dann auch die queen von schloss windsor
aus am britischen
auf geist und widerstandsfähigkeit in
ihrer fünften ausserordentlichen
ansprache in 68 jahren
wenn wir vereint und entschlossen
bleiben werden wie es durchstehen
ich hoffe wir werden irgendwann
zurückblicken und stolz darauf sein wie
jeder auf diese herausforderung reagiert
hat noch in dieser woche könnte das land
italien und spanien als den europäischen
krisenherd ablösen der premierminister
angeschlagen seine krisenpolitik
angezählt die herausforderung könnte
kaum größer sein
wichtig bei der bekämpfung der pandemie
ist möglichst schnell herauszufinden
welche kontakte ein infizierter hatte
die eu datenschutzbehörde fordert dafür
jetzt eine europaweite app das sei
besser als eine eigene lösung in jedem
staat in europa ist jetzt spanien das
land mit den meisten bestätigten
infektionen den dortigen behörden hoffen
aber dass der höhepunkt der epidemie
erreicht ist die zahl der toten steigt
seit tagen langsamer an
in den usa breitet sich das corona virus
weiter rasant aus kein land der welt hat
mehr bestätigte fälle im moment fast so
viel wie spanien italien und frankreich
zusammen
die nächsten zwei wochen würden wohl die
schlimmsten waren der präsident schon am
stärksten betroffen ist weiter new york
city in den überfüllten krankenhäusern
sind ärzte und pflegepersonal am limit
auch dort sei der höhepunkt der krise
noch nicht erreicht sagte bürgermeister
di blasi o deswegen will new yorks
gouverneur cuomo die strengen maßnahmen
gegen die virus ausbreitung bis ende
april aufrechterhalten
live aus new york zugeschaltet ist unser
korrespondent johannes hano wie ist die
lage im moment
also bürgermeister unter gouverneuren
gerade ihre pressekonferenzen gehalten
und der bürgermeister hat davon
gesprochen dass man sich jetzt überlege
vorübergehende gräber zu schaffen in
denen man die verstorbenen unterbringen
kann bis eine würdevolle bestattung
möglich ist er hat das wort massengräber
nicht in den mund genommen aber er hat
davon gesprochen wenn man das immer wenn
man das nicht mehr alleine schafft dass
man dann das militär bitten werde solche
gräber anzulegen die sollen aber erst
mal nur vorübergehend angelegt werden es
gibt aber auch lichtblicke
man hat gesagt wir haben es mittlerweile
genügend schutzausrüstung jetzt
zumindest für diese woche ist haben sich
20 tausend freiwillige aus dem ganzen
land gemeldet um die krankenhäuser zu
unterstützen und in dem brooklyn media
zu seinem fabrik aus dem boden gestampft
worden die jetzt 320.000 schutzkittel
produzieren will der gouverneur hat dann
die zahlen verkündet es sind wieder 600
tote schlimme zahlen aber er hat auch
davon gesprochen dass sich die zahl von
tag zu tag nicht weiter erhöht hat also
es könnte eine vorsichtige annahme sein
dass es sich ab fragt man will das aber
noch nicht feststellen
man sagt man muss das jetzt beobachten
ob es die nächsten tage so weitergeht
aber auf jeden fall sollen die maßnahmen
weiter bis ende april gelten sie haben
das gerade schon gesagt und er hat ganz
normal new york an klar gemacht er wird
das jetzt auch durchsetzt und er wird
die strafen erhöhen den jeder new yorker
habe die pflicht auch denjenigen die
über gegenüber die schwächer sind in der
gesellschaft und er werde das jetzt
durchsetzen von 500 auf 1000 dollar soll
die strafe steigen aber es gibt ein
bisschen hoffnung wenigstens denn auch
die kranken auslieferungen sind
zurückgegangen
dankeschön nach reagierens hannover das
rund um den globus ausgangssperren mit
zum teil dramatischen folgen
un-generalsekretär gute risch hat die
zunehmende gewalt gegen frauen und
mädchen in der korona pandemie scharf
verurteilt für viele sei die bedrohung
dort am größten wo sie am sichersten
sein sollten in ihrem eigenen zuhause in
manchen ländern habe sich die zahl der
frauen die hilfsangebote suchen
verdoppelt in afrika sind die zahlen von
infektionen und toten offiziell noch
eher gering die regierung südafrikas hat
schon grenzen und flughäfen geschlossen
und eine ausgangssperre verhängt
am größten ist die gefahr dort wo
hunderttausende dicht an dicht zusammen
leben und schon in normalen zeiten ums
nackte überleben kämpfen in den
townships sondern mit ihrem team in alex
unterwegs einem township von
johannesburg militär und polizei auf
patrouille in alexandra in südafrika
gilt eine der weltweit strengsten
ausgangssperren durchsetzen lässt sie
sich in den armenvierteln kaum zu viele
menschen leben hier eng an eng oft in
wellblechhütten wir sind viele
13 personen in einem haus wir haben gar
keine andere wahl
wir haben nur einen raum zum schlafen
wir leben mit unseren kindern und
enkelkindern alle zusammen auf engstem
raum
wie sollen wir da voneinander abstand
halten
die hygienischen bedingungen in den
townships sind katastrophal fließendes
wasser und toiletten gibt es meist nur
auf der straße viele familien teilen
sich die wasserstellen talent zulu macht
das virus angst sie versucht sich zu
schützen so gut es geht
wenn ich etwas angefasst habe oder je
nachdem was ich als nächstes tun
nehme ich wasser und wasche meine hände
mit seife wir brauchen
desinfektionsmittel sagt sie doch das
haben die wenigsten hier von masken ganz
zu schweigen
hinzu kommen die dramatischen
wirtschaftlichen folgen die
ausgangssperre trifft die ärmsten am
härtesten die arbeitslosigkeit ist in
gebieten wie diesen ohnehin schon riesig
viele menschen halten sich mit
gelegenheitsjobs über wasser leben von
tag zu tag von woche zu woche
jetzt sitzen sie in den häusern fest und
haben überhaupt keine möglichkeit an
einkommen zu generieren
wer ohne triftigen grund auf der straße
ist dem droht eine geld- oder haftstrafe
mittlerweile hat das virus mehrere
townships erreicht auch alexandra es
wird befürchtet dass es sich in den
armen vierteln besonders schnell
ausbreitet zurück nach deutschland
hierzulande sind osterferien die
karwoche traumhaftes wetter eigentlich
hochsaison für hotels doch fast alle
betten sind gezwungenermaßen leer
ein bericht aus der sächsischen schweiz
zeigt was das für uns bedeutet und das
zeigt auch dass die gerade noch einmal
aufgestockten kredithilfen der
bundesregierung mitunter wenig helfen
aus sachsen stellen
die sächsische schweiz derzeit
sperrgebiet für touristen die
haupteinnahmequelle der region ist damit
versiegt im hotel sebnitzer hof
verwalten sie den absturz vor zwei
wochen noch gut gefüllte bücher heute
nur noch stornierungen im postfach der
jungen unternehmerinnen besonders durch
das verbot von reisebus reisen das
trifft uns hier massiv wir haben über
1000 stornierungen erhalten in ihren
hotels beschäftigt sie 50 angestellte
betriebe dieser größe fallen bislang
durch alle hilfs netze doch nun soll es
auch für sie vom staat abgesicherte
kredite geben
unternehmerin steiger hätte allerdings
einen zuschuss gebraucht keinen kredit
weil natürlich ein kredit letztlich
zurückbezahlt werden muss mit der kurzen
laufzeit also erhöht das ende
kapitaldienst belastungen in den
nächsten jahren enorm und man versucht
diese krise jetzt zu überleben aber auch
sicherheit für die nächsten jahre zu
schaffen und die dann in eine
nachgelagerte krise zu kommen und was
heute nicht verdient wird kann im
hotelgewerbe niemals nachgeholt werden
sagt auch der landestourismusverband
nach ostern werden über 20% geschäft
unwiderruflich verloren sein
das bedeutet man kann ja ein bett was
heute nicht gebucht ist nicht zweimal
buchen im herbst insofern ist die
situation dramatisch
die sächsische schweiz hat schon
schlimme touristische flauten erlebt und
mehrere fluten überstanden aber so
schwierig wie diese krise war noch
keiner
ich habe schon existenzangst weil
niemand genau weiß wie lange die krise
geht was passiert und auch wie sich das
reiseverhalten danach entwickelt dieser
branche so sind sich hier alle einig
hilft nur geld was sie nicht
zurückzahlen muss weil sie es sowieso
nicht kann gleich nach dieser heute
sendung gibt es ein zdf spezial zur
corona krise unter anderem mit antworten
auf ihre zuschauer fragen
außerdem können sie sich über die zdf
heute app jederzeit informieren etwa in
unserem live-blog noch eine nachricht
zum thema diesel skandal 91.000 vw
kunden in großbritannien müssen
entschädigt werden das entschied ein
gericht in london
und sieht es als erwiesen an dass
volkswagen illegale software in
fahrzeuge einbaute und dann in
großbritannien verkauft hat um welche
summe es geht steht noch nicht fest vw
erwägt in berufung zu gehen
insgesamt hat der diesen skandal den
konzern schon mehr als 30 milliarden
euro gekostet
einen winzigen schritt zurück in die
normalität den haben heute fast alle
profi fußballvereine hierzulande gemacht
und wieder mit dem mannschaftstraining
angefangen bei eintracht frankfurt nur
in zweier grüppchen beim fc bayern
durften maximal fünf spieler gemeinsam
ran
alles im rahmen alles nach den regeln
des jeweiligen bundeslandes vielleicht
noch nicht ganz der gute alte fußball
aber für die kicker wohl allemal besser
als home office das home office weckt
aber auch kreative geister one world to
get die welt zusammen zu hause unter
diesem motto plant lady gaga am 18 april
eine live show zugunsten der korona
hilfe und sie hat schon eine
beeindruckende liste von mitstreitern
gewinnen können elton john zum beispiel
paul mccartney stevie wonder und mehr
was zum freuen zum freund ist auch das
wetter es bleibt prächtig und wird noch
wärmer die details dazu hat gleich katja
manöver claus kleber spricht im
heute-journal viertel vor zehn mit
vizekanzler scholz wir danken für ihr
interesse wünschen ihnen alles gute und
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren lange
hatten wir es mit dem hoch bei wann zu
tun heute abend hat es das schwarze meer
erreicht morgen kommt schon das nächste
hoch hoch norris und dann gibt es noch
ein schmales wolkenband ihr es ist eine
kleine kaltfront von tief an medias die
familie bringt aber so gut wie keinen
regen mit und wenn es doch mal regnet
dann wirklich nur in der nacht das
merken dann die meisten von uns wohl
nicht heute nacht also es ist meist
sternenklar und vor allen dingen am
alpenrand wird es kalt dort sinken die
temperaturen bis minus 2 grad unter den
dichteren wolken im nordwesten bleibt es
bei zehn bis sieben grad etwas milder
und morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen bei frühlingshaften
ja fast schon sommerlichen werten und
zwar über alle binnenland 18 bis 25 grad
werden dass und nur an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee bleibt es bei 14 15
grad etwas kälter und das liegt am
auflandigem wind das ist ein nord
nordwest wind der vom kalten wasser ins
binnenland hinein weht und das wasser
ist halt derzeit an nord und ostsee eben
noch richtigkeit
sonst gibt es viel sonnenschein und
daran ändert sich auch am mittwoch wenig
gründonnerstag kann es hier richtung
sauerland malen kleinen regenschauer
geben aber schon karfreitag ist es
wieder für uns alle trocken bei 12 bis
26 grad schön ab nach